I'm Pellom McDaniels, and I'm curator of African America collections
in the Stuart A. Rose manuscript archives and rare book library at Emory University.
Did you know that?
So the African American collections here contain materials related to
African American history and life
in terms of the social and political histories, art histories
We collect the papers of different organizations like the Southern Christian Leadership Conference,
which was started by Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
We also have collections of black fraternities and sororities
including The Boulé Sigma Pi Phi which is an African American men's professional fraternity.
Generally what we try to do is collect materials that are not only relevant to our
students and our faculty's research,
but fill in the gaps related to the lives of African Americans
from the beginning of the country's founding to today.
Our most recent acquisition, of course, was the Barack Obama letters from him to his girlfriend.
And so we have the first edition of Phillis Wheatley's book of poetry to the first black president's, you know,
letters before he was president. Really kind of showing us his
breadth and depth and his intelligence before he took office.
Some of the material that I'm interested in specifically has to do with
African American manhood and masculinity.
Historically speaking, when we think about African-American masculinity, we include slavery in that equation.
It was very difficult for black men to achieve a sense of manhood
being oppressed and being kind of identified as not only second-class citizens, but as beasts of burden,
as human chattels. And so by looking and tracing this history from slavery to freedom
we're able to see how these men were able to
accomplish the sense of their not only
manhood but achieved their humanity. And so in looking at,
reading the literature David Walker's Appeal, Du Bois' The Souls of Black Folk,
examining the the visual kind of representations of black masculinity as relates to early photography
we're able to understand how these men were defining themselves in this time period
where they were reduced to being less than human.
And so by looking at the different evidence we have available to us, we can really synthesize a
history, that is not only
significant for them in those moments where they experience life
but it allows for us to be rooted in something that brings us into the present.
It's like a big jigsaw puzzle
and, you know, my...
the beauty of my work is that I get a chance to go find the pieces to fill in the gaps and try to make it
as whole as I can in the space
provided in the archives.